eight days after Lisa Marie Presley was
laid to rest at Graceland the fight for
control of her estate begins welcome
everyone to Entertainment Tonight the
family battle officially starting with
Mom Priscilla who just made the first
big move contesting Lisa Marie's last
will and testament
nothing is sorted out yet everything's
trying to be sorted out and done with
dignity and done with care
Philip versus her own granddaughter if
Riley takes the issue with her
grandmother Priscilla being the trustee
then this could potentially pit them
against one another the legal Showdown
is shaping up after Elvis's Widow raised
suspicions in this 13-page filing
obtained by E.T in it Priscilla claims
Lisa Marie's signature on a 2016
amendment to her trust could have been
forged she also says the paperwork was
never delivered to her and misspelled
her name
so wait would Lisa Marie really want her
own mother cut out of her trust and
named daughter Riley as sole trustee
through the years the mother-daughter
relationship has been tense and
complicated that's Lisa Marie rolling
her eyes at her mom during a 2013
ET interview and while Elvis was a cool
dad my mom was completely the opposite
she was really strict so what's at the
center of this case the Priscilla
doesn't really stand to gain financially
in some significant Way by becoming the
trustee certainly she will be entitled
to some sums of money for actually doing
the job of the trustee but as far as the
money that is being inherited it doesn't
really affect the money that's going to
the beneficiaries here's what else we
know Lisa Marie was 16 million dollars
in debt at the time of her death there's
a new report claiming she had 35 million
in life insurance before she passed away
and of course there's Graceland which
brings in 110 million a year always has
been mine Graceland always will be and
when it's no longer mine it would be my
children's you know that's that in
another twist today TMZ is reporting
that Lisa Marie had lost 40 to 50 pounds
in the weeks leading up to the Globes
the website claims the 54 year old was
on weight loss medication and it started
taking opioids again the struggle in
addiction for me started it you know 45
years old Lisa Marie who was buried next
to her son Benjamin had also struggled
with the pain of his suicide in 2020.
survivors guilt some would say but a
broken heart was the doing of her death
[Music]